20-50 has been a fantastic year for
video games and this week we've seen the
launch of a bunch of great games some of
which we have been playing in beta for
what feels like most of 2050 brood yeah
there have been like I don't know like 7
13 14 beta something like that yeah one
of which being Rainbow six siege yeah oh
I meant for see specifically sorry yeah
that was just sees there were like you
know 25 or our subjects all the babies
right yeah that's the number creeps up a
little while Scott you reviewed it or
sorry you were in the process of
reviewing up for gamespot yeah aren't of
course we've had you on loads over the
years you've been playing a bunch threat
the various alphas and betas and it's
got first of all just before we sort of
get into the thick of it we have a
review in progress up on the site now
why is the full review not on gamespot
yet yeah well uh if people follow the
point which they absolutely should uh
you talk about embargoes a couple weeks
ago and this is one of those instances
where you saw it said embargo saying hey
you know this is when you can start
posting impressions and stuff like that
in in situations where we know we're
going to want to test the actual live
server cincy I mean CG is a
multiplayer-focused game it it exists
online that is the way to play it so
unless we can confirm that it actually
like functions properly unlike you know
good past example would be the master
chief collection didn't work last year
it was like a three weeks after the
launch of the game and it's it was still
not working yeah so we want to avoid
situations like that so when there's an
embargo and there's again just be tested
on line we will generally put up a
review in progress just let people know
hey here's what we don't have a full
review if you're seeing on other sites
if you're seeing other people post
impressions here's why we don't have a
full score review we're waiting we're
testing things primarily the servers but
there are other factors as well like
pacing of the progression other things
like that yeah you were gonna say
something mean typically when we go to
review events they set up an ideal
situation we're all sitting in a room
with perfect servers and everything
works great yeah my was network yeah i
mean i've played Rainbow six siege today
on both pc and ps4 and i've actually
encountered a lot of bugs that i ran
into in the beta like getting stuck
crouching and having to go prone to get
out of it and over the rubber banding
and like a number of things that i'm not
sure if it's just a day 1 launch issue
but again like they're the kinds of
things that we didn't see the review
event and today
hey I've had a lot of brokenness that
being says it feel like its network in
laser the game what the game
communicates to the player and I can't
confirm this entirely but i think it's
hosted on somebody's machine so it's
dependent probably on who the connection
to that person's a machine being good so
does it seem like some games are running
better than others yeah it's very
inconsistent like some when everything
works being like on a high level when
everything works in rainbow CJ it's one
of my favorite games so far this year
just because i haven't had a game that's
really got my heart going like that in a
long time yeah like to change the
tension when it works is pretty
incredible speaking quickly i guess just
you've got the it's like the most
thankless job in the world is reviewing
especially a game like this because not
only do you have to account for the
quality of the game and also its
technical issues but you can only ever
witness your technical issues i member
you people some people you know post
reviews of games and they don't have
like for instance we had Jeff Grossman
on this show for fall I have a couple of
weeks ago went really bad problems on
consoles I pay 30 hours i think or 20
hours maybe of flat I for one ps4 hadn't
encountered anything like he was yeah so
are you experiencing the same stuff
irony is is it no actually my experience
today at least has been pretty smooth
I've been playing on ps4 all morning so
I think erin was primarily experiencing
issues on PC from what he's told me so
that they getting stuck buck was ps4 and
a guy on the chat told me how to get out
of it so he clearly had this interesting
yeah I'm absolutely ran into this before
in past reviews I can't think of a good
example of time ahead but I've
definitely had encountered situations
where i wrote a review published in the
comics row what about this book whatever
this book i'm like it's just it never
happened to me i don't know what to tell
ya so i am trying to be mindful of that
i am talking to other people about their
experiences with the game i am trying to
see how often those sorts of issues come
up how consistent they are four other
people i mean if it's just a one-off or
a single person maybe not worth
mentioning the review if it's something
that everyone besides me is experiencing
probably worth bringing up so we'll get
to that i guess in the review when it's
on gamespot i'm guessing later this week
sometimes yes hopefully end of day
wednesday maybe early Thursday something
along that it depends on how quickly i'm
able to progress through the game again
progression is another thing that I
really want to test and yeah it seems
like relatively slow to unlock new stuff
although I was originally told that you
could only play pvp after reaching a
certain level turns out there
is actually a casual PvP mode that's
available from the start so that's good
to know you can jump in and just play
online right Peavy ranked is locked it's
basically they're hardcore mode is what
they're saying right and although i
haven't eaten sleep properly it does
remove a lot of like a in-game help like
you know in casual PvP you have a
grenade indicator like hey grenadiers
who passed you know by linking and let
you know that you should move yeah but
in ranked that will not be there and
there are other are they trying to like
limit people getting into rying to don't
you should be in right the game has
basically the game can have a pretty
steep learning curve if you haven't
played the betas before it's a very
tactical game and like people have
played for a while are gonna know a lot
more than you do yeah lots of different
characters lots of like nuance and yeah
there's a lot you know like I think
their intention was to have you play
through their situations which is
basically like training that's enough to
get you up to five operators unlocked
and then of the 22 of the 20 total and
then you can play terrorist hunt that'll
start getting your renowned credits up
that's the coop single-player kind of
Iraq yeah it's your team versus a set
number of AI or potentially an infinite
number of AI if you have to go in and
disarm determine bomb so is that are
those the two single player aspects of
the game there's a sort of the training
situation stuff and then there's the
terrorists own does that sort of AI
single phase yeah you can play
terrorists on turn around although it's
really designed for co-op the only truly
like single player only portion of the
game or these situations which I mean it
it kind of borders on a campaign like
had there been more like directed
moments and and sort of unique gameplay
moments injected into the experience and
had there been more story tying it all
together it would have basically been a
campaign like it's they're pretty robust
for like just calling them training
missions kind of under sells what they
are but I know I mean it's a
sixty-dollar game so you kind of think
that's but have some it does feel like
this a bit of opinion it could have used
three campaigns I think they put a ton
of effort into making these operator
videos for each one of the operators
cutscenes which are going to watch one
time it feels like if they just put that
energy into making cutscenes for the
situation's they would have had a
campaign yeah like and the interesting
there's the there's a germ of a story in
it i mean the intro to the game like the
cutscene you watch when you first put
the disc in talks about basically the
creation of the rainbow six like what
rainbow six is not as if nobody
remembers yes this was originally a Tom
Clancy novel like there is actually like
a universe here that you
draw from to create an actual story in
the opening cutscene hints at that but
then the rest is really touchy on it
like you you could have like there was
room for a narrative you could have done
some stuff and but then again you know
who knows plenty people who play call of
duty like I'm there I'm played
single-player years so it's like where
do you focus your resources let's talk
about the actual multiplayer itself yeah
let's talk about the shooting one of the
modes how does it play does it have
longevity so the most important thing to
know about C's especially the PvP is it
it's very kind of unforgiving it's it's
set up in a very deliberate manner it's
there are no response you give one life
per round that's it it's no more than
five versus five um so it's it's a very
controlled in particular set up there is
no straight like running gun respond
team deathmatch more of a counter-strike
than a call of duty it's it's even more
tactical the counter strike it's very
deliberately paced I mean every round
actually opens with a sort of planning
phase where defenders will be able to
set up traps and sort of fortify their
position and attackers will be able to
use remote-control drones to scout out
and find objectives and Erin and I've
been talking about how crucial that
phase this I mean it sounds a little dry
like I you're driving your drone around
you're gonna you know mark your enemies
and all that kind of stuff but seriously
it's such a crucial time saver if you
know where your objective is before
around starts you're not kind of running
around aimlessly you can actually plan
with your teammates what you're gonna do
and how you're gonna infiltrate one of
the things very tactical one of the
things that will give this game
longevity I think is just the variety of
stuff that can happen in around right
yes for starters there's a lot of maps
there was a ton of maps that we didn't
even see it the review event and that's
fantastic i'm gonna be talking like 15
it was pretty much every almost every
matt from the situation i've said
minimum 10 i didn't seem like i might I
think it's all the maps you've seen in
beta plus maps from situations and then
each one of those maps has multiple
locations multiple times of day right
and then just like tactics will switch
you know we we played against a team
where they just love to like laid out in
corners and we figure that out yeah and
then they had to like switch up their
whole their whole tactics once we get
that's the great thing it's all about
moves and countermoves like once you
figure out your opponent strategy you
can react to it and they have to react
to a reaction right and it's great that
it actually allows for that kind of
creativity and strategic depth I mean
it's not just if you just run the room
and tried gun people down you're
probably gonna die on and is it's so
great that there's again room for
creativity and also mind games and
things like
you can bust out boards and you know you
can fortify a door and if you bust out
one board you can potentially trick the
other team of thinking that you're just
crouched waiting for them and use it as
a distraction or you like set up a
breach charge on a door you're not
actually going through and then
detonated remotely and come in another
way there are all these different
techniques that you can employ to give
yourself an advantage and it's great
that you're given the tools and given
the opportunity to actually do all that
stuff rather than just again mindlessly
running gun the game also has something
that is so neglected in so many
multiplayer games which is mixed mode
servers right like mixed mode just adds
so much longevity you don't know which
you're not you don't know they're going
to be defending a bomb attacking a bomb
a hostage like yeah you're right that is
weirdly falling falling out of vogue in
the basket like again battlefront was a
perfect game where like Battlefront
through everything against the wall in
terms of modes but then they didn't have
a mixed mode server so every life form
apps you just got bored and had to go
search for something else to do by
having mixed modes in this it just adds
so much variety to what I'm doing and
the operators and all the gadgets as
well so each of the 20 operators has a
unique item or ability that they can use
and that helps to crepe right as well
especially since you have to unlock them
and it does feel kind of earned when you
have to pick and choose and very
gradually earn new new characters and
new ability okay I last question on this
because it sort of comes into the you
know when people are asking is this game
I want to play you know this the amount
of single-player stuff and what's better
self or something important another
thing especially what's parachuters is
is this the type of game where you
really should be playing with four of
your friends or is it fun enough playing
with random that's part of what we're
figuring out i mean i was talking with
somebody earlier today like i don't
think you can hold a game accountable
for its its audience and you can't be
like oh the playerbase sucks therefore
the game is bad but it gives you give a
joinable if a game is built to be
team-based it is the game's job to equip
players with the tools they need to
effectively communicate to educate
players how to use those and to
incentivize her and entice that type of
gameplay if you're built to be a team
placed team based game you need to make
players play that way give them a reason
to play the way and give them the
ability to play that way it may be a
simple version of a but you can imagine
a version of rocket League for instance
which didn't educate the player in those
ways needed
via like the chat stuff and via just
like you know the way the way you can
Center the ball and that becomes like a
focus like yeah that type of thing is
crucial to a game being fun a special
thing around in people right the best
experience is definitely gonna be on
Mike with a good team or just a minimum
on Mike simply because there's things
that you can't communicate such as
reinforce this wall like I put armor
over here hey don't don't blow up that
wall we need it or don't reinforce that
wall we need it yeah these are taking
sexual versus the things that the game
doesn't have tools for you to
communicate without just getting on
voice chat so yeah you know finding a
good group of people like when you when
you play with good people just you know
friend up with them yeah and that'll be
the best cuz ya know it makes a huge
difference the people you're playing
with and so far I've had pretty good
experiences and again you can't
necessarily hold the game responsible
for that but if you have the option to
play people you know or at least people
who care have microphones yeah do it the
game is way better when you have those
people playing with you excellent
Scotland thank you so much for coming on
get out there and keep playing moremore
succeeds because we need to get that
review up on the side yeah I better look
at that and thanks so much for coming on
and talking about it of course and let
us know what you think our rainbow 6
siege have you been playing the beta
you're playing on pc or on the console
let us know in the comment box below
you